thank you very much I don't need that
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to guardian angel if you
know about the weeping angels from
Doctor Who you definitely know about the
weeping angels that are put in video
games because the mechanic is very very
very similar so this is guardian angel
but it's not a good thing because these
things aren't watching over me to
protect me
no they're watching over me to kill me
dead show let's just see how close to
the real thing these actually are oh
wait wait a minute
hey okay well there we go so just that
easy how just like that and we touch
down we go boom okay well then I guess
we just go through these wonderful
forest can't believe I survived that
considering it's upside down and on fire
but we're gonna forget that for just a
moment and try to go wherever we're
going
is this Lending's forest I'm zipping I
like the little wind lines on the edges
of the screen that's nice Spoleto bros
Oh something bad about the spout at the
Bros or whatever it doesn't matter to me
I still gotta keep moving forward Oh
guardian angel I already told them that
no I can't run forever oh bunker hmm how
nice and you guys why are you all whoa
whoa
well that was Doctor Who's speech but
okay oh oh hi oh that's pretty cool
oh wow oh that's so cool
who's ready to go me I'm ready let's do
this baby oh oh [ __ ] okay how do I blink
not that I want to blink but I just I
just wanted to know how to avoid it
alright whatever have you I suppose I'm
gonna be okay until I run into a whole
lot of not okay we I gotta find six
watches six whooshes well there's one on
the ground for some reason swoosh huh
why did that Oh laser that's not right
oh but that make go sent to Kemah follow
the path there's multiple paths god damn
it I'm gonna fall whatever path I'd go
upon and hope it's for the best
I don't see you know angels is this
alright let's get here
where's this gmod map ass [ __ ] oh that's
not good oh that's the sound of
something not good hey son come back
wait no there's a grave here why rip-rip
aroni
here lies Lou T P Schmidt okay it's real
dark
it's like stupid dark this is redonk a
dark woman looking at its f-fire it's on
my plane oh wait this is all the way
back to the base so that is my plane
okay well it's still really dark it's
dickly dark oh I didn't want that kind
of light thank you very much I don't
need that
where did you come from where did you
come from I'm not blinking
I'm not blink belong king I'm not I'm
not I'm not
can you stop that can you no no okay
I don't know where I'm going in a boom
oh you're gone now okay
yes sure yeah okay sure I don't want
that hey hey hey hey hey hey no no no no
no no one's limey I don't know what find
me oh alright don't like that oh oh I
don't like that oh I have no idea I
can't see [ __ ] I can't see a [ __ ] I
can't see a [ __ ] oh oh that's not good
ok there's something off to the left
over there I gotta go over there I don't
know if there's one in front of me or
near me or what it what have you no no
listen listen now listen now listen
listen now listen now listen oh wait a
minute this is a business gang enough I
don't know where you are I don't know
where you are I don't know where you
where oh god what was I supposed to do
what the [ __ ] was I supposed to do what
was I supposed to do nothing I was
supposed to do a whole lot of dick and a
little bit of diddly and that's what I
did this is a 2 fee that's just 2 feet
tough Oh God not this give me give me
just kill me already you're gonna do it
anyway why don't you just kill me maybe
that may be the strategy is I gotta go
as fast as I possibly can without
running out of stamina cuz it's kind of
a loop it's definitely a loop around the
island to get to where I need to be but
I don't know if it's advantageous to run
or just walk away from them because they
once there once or more of them
comes quite a problem oh-o-oh the flash
a light oh the flash you lie I didn't
know there was a flash light how was I
supposed to know there was a flash light
all right just a big [ __ ] idiot I'm
gonna explore the other side of the
island first because this in case
there's ones over there that I haven't
hit I want to see them so that I know
where they are before I actually get to
him okay so there's two in quick
succession right here and these might
have been the last ones that I needed
not sure but here we go anyway long all
right we got one flunk er all right
second plonk Oh going up and there they
come
yeah there goes the light oh no the
flashlight is much much better much
infinitely a lot better infinitely
better oh hello
I don't know if I've seen this one
before it was kind of tucked away in the
hills here but okay flunk did I get it
did not okay there's another one
what is this sound oh you're really here
they come not hundreds ensure where they
are but they're coming I know they are
hey listen listen no need I think that's
just messing with me I think this is a
random noise that's orbiting around my
head for no particular reason
number four baby number four all right
come on but no where whoa no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no that's good baby
you've flown in midair like a loser Oh
another one oh I got to see yeah I got
two Z's I got to do Z's
okay where am I going by the way I have
no idea whoa hey whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa oh there's there's one okay well
well well well well well well well none
of that whoa whoa whoa whoa easy easy
easy easy breezy beautiful covergirl
okay so they don't like the light they
don't they don't like that they don't
like that one bit they don't like okay
there's the last one no that's not the
last one okay I got you I got you guys
ah we're back we're okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay the other one was to the
right over here I think it was just back
over here I think this has got to be it
right unless I'm going towards where I'm
not supposed to go oh [ __ ] okay then it
must have been back up this way I think
it was whoo you disappeared you're the
tree oh oh I'm a fall this path that I'm
on cuz I think it's gonna lead exactly
where I need to go
well why Oh whoa-ho-ho-ho
did you just try to break my what did
you what did you [ __ ] just try to
break my neck
did you [ __ ] right where where where
my neck my neck hey no no no no no okay
why stop right now stop right now okay
it's gotta be I know there was another
one that was tangentially related to
these ones here I know there was one I
know there was one I know there was one
I just die you stupid crap I what the
hell I know there's one around here you
think I would have seen it already go
out I have it Hey whoa whoa okay four of
you now four of yes that that's it
that's it that's the one I'm walking
right towards it right for it right for
right for is it right No Wow where'd it
go
I've lost it I can't see it now oh god
I've lost it no no you floaty bastards
no oh god damn it that's the edge of the
map okay not that way
no I just saw that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah there it is that's the one I
know no whoa that's a string of you ah
was the last one okay I got it all run
to the bunker I will I will do that I
will do exactly that and I know where it
is cuz of the light oh hey how's it
going hi friend how are you how are you
good you good brother yeah you're good
oh it's farther than I thought it was
okay we're gonna
close close close close close close
close close goes boom I did it wait did
I do it
we didn't why did they do it what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] I meant the bunker
this is the bunker Oh dad oh oh if I'd
have died if I'd had died because I went
to the wrong end of the bunker I would
have been infinitively pissed but I
didn't because I'm great
so that was guardian angel I don't like
my guardian angels my guardian angels
are sacks of [ __ ] so let's forget about
the guardian angels let's try to avoid
it but the game pretty dang good kind of
a slender thing but I like it it's
smooth it worked well the gameplay was
nice the sounds were good the angels
were scary so I don't mind it one bit so
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to try to play this game for
yourself I'll leave a link in the
description as always and apparently
there's gonna be more levels as soon as
they get the funding to do so so thank
you again and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]